if you can't make the economics of an ad
channel exciting
can you at least a not burn money while
b
building a huge lead database that that
likes you because your free thing or
your cheap thing
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back
i'm actually uh i'm surprised you
haven't been on this before i feel like
i feel like you're made for this in a
way
maybe i mean i was doing pods for a
while like i was trying like purposely
to get on podcasts
for like indie hackers yeah for like
getting the word out about demand curve
then at some point i'm like
this is cringe man like i don't like
listening back to myself
and so it took the process of actually
starting a podcast uh you know in part
thanks to also watching you do your your
magic to be like you know what i can
just totally be myself not to worry
about it as much and then it stopped
being cringed so now i'm all for it
and how how has it been since you
launched the pod so you launched uh
what's called brains right brains with
the s or without the s yeah brains with
the s it's been good it's been
i guess it is rare to have
reasons in your life to be very
seriously self-reflective about whether
or not you're boring the out of
people
it's like i have to be so deliberate
about can i be charismatic can i be
interesting and i'm not saying i'm there
yet but i'm saying i'm at least thinking
about it you know in in the context of
trying to not bore people on a podcast
so it's been a really good forcing
function okay i like that and uh has it
been
so you launched this podcast you did it
very methodically you recorded like
eight
episodes with badass people ahead of
time
and uh so i feel like you were pretty
thorough about how you went about it or
more so than me at least um
did it go the way you wanted to or where
did you learn
yeah i was thorough because i felt that
i kind of had no choice because i
listened to a bunch of podcasts and
found most of them to be like
unlistenable right and then when i heard
my first million i'm like there's
something special here but i don't
actually know what it is
and so my co-host on the podcast
cortland from indie hackers he's like
what's going on here that special
is they're not asking boring interview
questions they're literally just
riffing on ideas collaboratively
and making charged statements and
letting other people respond to them
and the net effect is it feels way more
like rapport like a dinner conversation
you're overhearing so we really rolled
with that and then we try to be
deliberate about well how do we choose
guests that can actually play into that
can they speak spontaneously are they
willing to play ball and bad ideas
around right so i feel like it's
probably a lot of the stuff that you're
thinking about as well and yeah it's
been it's been great so we're basically
you know in a way we're my first million
but for everything outside of business
like writing a book being a storyteller
you know what i mean
yeah the episode i was on had uh
uh alexandra botez i don't know how you
say her name actually how do you say it
properly that's right example because
she got it chess
champion uh twitch streamer so she's
like content creator really interesting
person
her content is about chess because she's
really damn good at chess um
and so i found it pretty interesting
like that was not what like i've been on
a bunch of podcasts that's not usually
what i get to to talk about or talk to
and uh so i immediately was pretty
bought in just as i kind of guessed on
it but anyways
i wanted to have you on here because
uh this is you know the pod for ideas
and i feel like you have a lot of
interesting ideas and also see a lot of
interesting ideas and for people who
don't know
we're in a group chat together and being
in a group chat is like the closest
thing to being in a dorm together i feel
you get to know people over time you get
to see them walking around in their
boxers you know you you just you're
going to the shared bathroom together
there's no place to run you're going to
be yourself over
in enough time in the right group chat
so i feel like i've gotten to know you
even though we have never met in person
uh
but you are an ideal person do you
consider yourself an ideal person
um i see i think of myself as someone
who just loves to brainstorm but i'm not
as fixated on ideas i think as you are
like i know you and sam
love the treasure hunt you love the
chase like who's making money how i'm
more like all right give me a problem i
want to solve the problem and so what i
did for this show actually is i went
through the community of my startup we
have about 40 000 marketers and and
founders and so i picked out the three
most interesting growth trends i could
find and i came with some examples of
each of those trends so there were like
three things that were popping out
that felt almost like cheat codes like
ways that startups were
printing cash and reaching unicorn
status much quicker than one would think
they should okay so that's something we
can jam on i got a few three categories
there we can jam on if you like yeah
let's do that right now don't even say
anything else besides that i'm i'm
completely i'm completely hooked let's
do that
all right all right so okay let's kick
it off with this first category
so i'm going to give these funny names
because i don't have good names for them
so category one is give customers an
absolute no-brainer so there's two ways
to give them a no-brainer that i've seen
in the community no-brainer number one
is you literally give them away money in
a way that's economically sustainable
which we'll get into right another
no-brainer way
is make the friction so crazy low
that people are like ah it i'll
just click the button one time and get
this installed so let's walk through
examples of what i mean by that so
starting with giving away money there
was this product a long time ago called
service
and what they did is they would give you
money back
any time that your flight was delayed
if a few conditions were true because
there was this lesser-known loophole in
the contracts of airlines where for
loyalty reasons they wanted to have a
policy to give flyers some money back if
their site was delayed you just have to
do the paperwork and request it and
nobody ever did it exactly right no one
wanted the friction so service is like
hey we'll automate we'll create like a
va army we'll file the paperwork for you
you just give us your itinerary we're
literally
giving you cash
almost literally because it's like
credit so the reason this was so clever
is for a very simple reason it wound up
creating
some of the world's best performing ads
because when you made ads on facebook
that were something like hey did you
know the airlines will pay you up to a
hundred bucks whenever you're delayed
the click-through rates on those ads
were astronomical the cost per click
were super low
and they were able to yeah to just
skyrocket to millions and ad spend
monthly very quickly
and let me give you a couple more
examples
because this is actually something
more than just service could do so
another interesting example is a recent
yc company
and they're called yada so yada does is
they'll take your money just go to
normal bank they'll take your money you
know they'll manage savings
but because they're so low overhead they
they redistribute all of that extra
potential margin into lottery winnings
for their bank customers so just by
having more money in yada they are going
to give you tickets to this vert to this
real lottery that they run every single
week they give away millions
and you just you're automatically
entered just due to some income no no
loss so imagine no loss lotteries called
right yeah exactly and just imagine
their ads
like just think about how compelling it
is to position that to a lot of people
who either love the lottery
or just really want a way to make extra
cash so a couple more examples if it's
helpful for me to run through here
we got
main street that's when you said it
that's the one that came to mind as soon
as you said
give you know basically giving away
money i thought of main street as a
company that's growing fast doing this
it's brilliant right and so so explain
explain what it is if people don't know
so
they're basically running ads i'll come
at it from the perspective of what is
the ad because that's the whole
perspective of this chat it's like
what's the growth right so the ad main
street can run to people is did you know
that you're
not taking advantage of an extra say ten
thousand dollars in tax credits
every year for your business it's like
whoa if i'm a small business making it
month to month
that's huge
and so again they found a business model
that can act as a means to at least
optically
without being a scam either give you
like free money in a sense or credit
back and it functions as the ultimate
acquisition wedge in a sense
which then becomes how they grow so darn
quickly and so the question is
how do these companies make money and
this brings us to this idea of like
having a wedge in the growth world we
talk about wedges or even investing
and if you can just use one of these
products as a means to collect emails
and happy customers very quickly
then it's a wedge into building a
customer base that you can monetize
through other revenue streams if not
that one revenue stream itself right
yeah i like that a lot and there was
another one that was doing this um or do
not pay is another one that does this
right they uh i think i don't remember
how they started if it was them or
somebody else there was another one that
was like the flight flight cancellation
payback there was one that was hey did
you get a parking ticket in san
francisco we'll fight it for you so just
send us a picture of the ticket we will
fight it for you did you know that you
know 4 out of 10 tickets are filled out
incorrectly and are therefore invalid
even if you were in the wrong the cop
filled it out wrong and therefore you
don't have to pay a dime we we will find
these opportunities for you and you only
pay us out of the savings of whatever
money we save you we'll take 20
of whatever money we give back to you um
and i thought wow that's actually like
a great idea and it got so popular that
san francisco banned them
um you know pretty quickly after a few
months because it was like being used so
much
same with service by the way service the
airlines were like what what the hell is
going on here and they just shut it they
like close they started tightening up
the policy and so sometimes
that actual wedge can be a very flimsy
one yeah but if you if you ran away with
happy customers who now trust you for
other products
then maybe it was still an okay one so i
wouldn't necessarily recommend these
flimsy unsustainable channels but but
main street does not seem flimsy to me
right on paper another great example
i'll give you one last one because
it's my favorite because it's under
everybody's noses which is if you look
at the top of buildings when you're
driving around you have those clear view
you know these billboard ads
and so imagine being a business owner
and someone comes to you and says hey
i'm going to pay you let's say
50 grand a year
all you got to do is put this billboard
on your roof right i'm sure it's much
more complicated than that but the idea
is that sometimes when you get pitched
with
a revenue stream that's super low
friction for you that you did not
realize is possible it just becomes a
crazy growth wedge yeah that's yeah and
there's you could basically create value
out of thin air just by
just just by knowing the rules of
connecting the dots i feel this way
about there's some bigger businesses
that do this principle
um
one for student loan refinancing it's
just like hey
you're paying too much
just
tell us what you pay today and we will
find you a cheaper student loan you just
click a button and and boom you change
to this monthly payment instead of this
one i think uh common bond or something
like that is one of those and house
refinancing is another but these require
it's not as they can't do the whole
thing on your behalf unfortunately but
i'm
i feel like somebody could get closer to
doing the whole thing on your behalf um
and that seems like a pretty big
opportunity to me absolutely and what
this actually speaks to is
this larger trend of
can you think of your product roadmap if
you're starting a business
in unison with your growth roadmap
because everything we've just been
discussing is basically
a product feature it's not like you're
just running ads
in a silo you're running ads because you
have this way of giving away money or at
least the optically giving way money so
i tell founders sometimes
can you think of the feature list on
your product roadmap can you
reprioritize it such that it facilitates
growth strategies like these
and that can guide you for growing a lot
quicker as opposed to just you know
living in a local maximum running in
circles
and so
because we're ultimately talking about
the idea like a trojan horse here for
acquiring customers in a non-scammy and
authentic way where you're really
offering value so the other half of this
by the way is
this idea is mentioning of
super low friction
so this we're still under this category
of
giving customers an absolute no winner
no brains
exactly how do you become a no-brainer
where it's like i don't have to think
about this
so second sub-category so first was
giving away money second is super low
friction so let me give you an example
chrome extensions are maybe my favorite
example because if we think of honey
right which gives you it's a chrome
extension that as you browse the web it
surfaces discounts on whatever you're
browsing right right you're looking at a
chair it'll say
you didn't know this but you can get 20
off
so
that's brilliant because the chrome
extension is like a two-click process
from being part of your internet
browsing experience for until the rest
of time until you delete the extension
right it's so low friction you don't
have to sign up you don't have to add a
credit card you don't have to give any
of your data verified via two-factor
authentication verify your email address
none of it you don't even have to
remember to open the app right that's
most apps you just
person just forgets to open you ever
again but with chrome extension they're
opening chrome they already have that
habit you just get to tag along like a
little you know like the flea on an
elephant's back
exactly that's right and so if you can
find a way to make something so painless
where it's like two clicks i didn't
forget it the idea is that now you're
around now you have a bunch of exposure
opportunities you keep popping up when
relevant on web pages that the user is
browsing and eventually when the time is
right and you can deliver real value
like contextually because like this is
going to be a monster coupon i could
give the customer we're going to save
them a thousand bucks right that's when
you finally ask hey
can you make an account real quick
before we give you this monster coupon
and now they're completely bought in and
they've come to trust you yeah that's
smart what other chrome extension ideas
uh have you have you seen that you like
or you have like what else is like honey
does anything come to mind i know it's a
hard question but
what else is like honey yeah it is a
tough question but
one good example is
extensions in the seo space
that give you data about web pages yeah
the competitive analysis as you're
browsing so that if you are a marketer
you can get this like x-ray vision into
how are they growing right what are they
what keyword terms and all this stuff
right so it winds up educating you to
better grow your business and becomes
very sticky if that date is valuable
um what which which chrome extensions
which chrome extensions do you have
installed i have similar web which is
what you're talking about basically
gives me traffic information about
different websites so i can see how
popular they are and where the traffic
comes from
i have meta mask which is a you know an
ethereum wallet uh or a crypto wallet
and then i have adblock those are the
three chrome extensions i have and i'm
very particular about chrome extensions
because when you install a chrome
extension it says
this extension can read
everything you type into any website i'm
like wow that's so insecure that's crazy
what do you have installed yeah so
nothing exciting i got my ad block
i got the thing that tells me if i'm on
a website that had their passwords sort
of broken into so it'll tell me if i
should switch my password you know
um and then i have um
uh oh this awesome twitter extension
that when i'm looking at someone's
twitter profile it'll show me all their
historical best performing tweets so i
get like a snapshot view of who they are
and what they're known for it's called
t-w-e-m-e-x like twee max i like that
that's pretty cool i was thinking there
could be a couple others like uh while
you were saying that i was thinking what
other x-ray you said extra vision i like
that so i was like what x-ray vision
would i want as i browse the web so one
is just taking uh like the twitter thing
but sort of like anytime someone's name
is on a web page if i just hover can i
just pop out a thing that basically
tells me
about that person it's like here's you
know here's the twitter profile you can
click follow here are some things about
them here's the wiki or whatever so it's
like
you know the quick who is this on any
name on any website that's one the other
is um
facebook ads so i i'm constantly going
to the facebook ad library to find what
ads a company is running i actually just
want that done automatically so i just
want to go to any
products website any any company's
website and be able to click this and
see what ads they're running without
having to go open up the ad library
yeah i love that the um
the way i think about this this type of
a question is like what type of chrome
extension or like what's the framework
for thinking about
which category of chrome extension would
be the stickiest and would people love
to download the most
and i think about how to appeal device
like how do i appeal to people's desire
to make money and so where my brain goes
right away is what about some sort of
x-ray vision where you're on like
bloomberg or you're on twitter anytime
the chrome extension picks up a keyword
for a public stock or like some crypto
token right cryptocurrency then it just
suggests um like it gives you an x-ray
into like how it's performing who else
talks about it a lot who should you fall
to learn more about this right and that
then it kind of triggers more so like
this greedy like okay well i can make
money off this so i'm gonna pay a bit
more attention because when you do the
educational route really with any tool
okay let's give x-ray vision let people
know like amazon's x-ray vision when
you're watching a movie it'll tell you
like what music is playing in the
background who are these actors like do
people really care i mean maybe some but
it's probably nerds
yeah yeah the the the
one more on this is uh that i was just
thinking of
while you're browsing websites if it
basically could you create robinhood in
a chrome browser a chrome extension i
think you could so
you could basically have it be like
acorns where it sort of rounds up on
anything you buy
and then it buys either a fraction of
that stock or it adds up until you it
tells you hey you've been shopping a lot
on apple why don't you buy a hundred
dollars of apple stock click here to do
it and maybe there's a way to kind of
like use that roundup model to get you
to own instead of just being a customer
and not owning any of the underlying
company in which case you could so i
think this is one interesting idea is
just look at every app on your phone and
say
could this be a chrome extension how
would you do robinhood as a chrome
extension how would you do blah blah
that's super clever so to recap that
you're basically saying as i'm browsing
like literally as i'm on robinhood.com
right can there be an acorns it can be
some acorns like extension that's like
hey why don't you spend a little bit
more and actually invest directly in
this company exactly and get a sense of
ownership and incentive alignment or
even better like hey we like it it pops
up right as it sees you're about to do a
trade it's like hey we see about the
trade for like 97 bucks you want to roll
this up get the extra three bucks in
robin hood itself yes that's that's
super clever i love that all right so
that was that was theme one uh let's go
to theme two sure so let's see here
okay
so this next category is
does encouraging people to use your
product
naturally encourage other people they
know to use the product also this is
commonly called product led growth but
we can break it down into more
interesting ways let me start by giving
you some examples okay so slat connect
dropbox paypal calendly so what these
companies have in common is when i use
any of those products
my use of that product
is better if i invite other people onto
it or share it with other people like
when i join slack it's a ghost town if
it's just me right right so i'm
naturally encouraged to to invite my
co-workers and then slack did something
super brilliant called slack connect
where now i can invite non-co-workers so
people who exist like at different
people who work at different companies
and i'm using slack as the glue but
because i'm using slack as the glue i
need to go invite those people to start
using slack so we can communicate on our
you know whatever service contract we
got going on
so
the idea behind product led growth the
first half of the idea is that you use
the product in a way that benefits you
when you invite more people so you're
going to do it without them having to
bribe you with five bucks to invite your
friends because you're gonna do it
anyway right and then the back half of
product that growth
is
when your friends receive your invite or
when you share that product with your
friends they have to feel that signing
up for the product
is also beneficial for them so let me
give you an example like if i
dropbox someone a file
they could just take the file as it is
but if they signed up for dropbox
well now they're going to get version
history now they're not going to have to
store it on their hard drive or in the
email it's going to be like this thing
that they can more easily manipulate to
the dropbox software or let's say i'm
sending someone a paypal payment
well guess what if you want my money you
got to sign up for paypal like you
literally have to sign up in order to
get the money right um
and for calendly same thing like when
i'm sharing my calendar link you know
the software for calendar booking
the person who's receiving the link has
a much better experience if they
themselves sign up for calendly because
it'll show them when they have over
overlapping time windows right that are
free so that's the trick behind product
let growth
both parties have to benefit
and if you look at the fastest growing
companies of the last few years a lot of
them grew in exactly this way where you
don't have to rely on seo which can be
super flimsy when google makes algorithm
updates
you don't have to rely on like paid
acquisition meaning ads so facebook if
the cpm's rise at the cost rise
and is so healthy and robust and
retentive and so that's the obvious part
though so the less obvious part
is this idea that i call billboarding
and billboarding is a subtype of
product-led growth
that is my favorite because anyone can
do it you don't have to be a software
company and i'll give you the og example
of billboarding if i sign up for hotmail
and i send an email and you know where
i'm going with this which is there's
that hotmail signature in the email
right
or if i send with my iphone there's that
sent from my phone in the email
signature right right and like how many
millions of people every day get beaten
over the head was sent from my iphone
and it's just a phenomenal way to stay
top of mind
so
we also have the clear view example the
billboards from earlier like we were
saying it was such a brilliant business
because
it was giving people money but it's also
brilliant because guess what they do
whenever they put a billboard up
they throw their logo on the billboard
right
so that's billboarding literally in the
truest like definition and then i'll
give you one last example
which is my favorite because
it's like blowing up right now i can't
stop just like i'm i'm subject to it i
can't stop seeing this
and it's mercury
oh actually actually that is that's
better than my example because they're
they're they're making it they're like
people make it their profile right so
crypto punks are an nft and if you go
buy it cool you bought this digital file
it sits in your digital wallet
privately and there's no you know it's
even worse display than art because
you're not putting it in a frame in your
house but what people started doing was
they put it in the most visible frame
they have their profile photo so they're
swapping their twitter profile photo
with a crypto punk and one person
started doing it in two three four and
then more started doing it
and so now i can't use twitter without
seeing crypto punks and
reminding myself how i missed out on
crypto punks and so i feel like that's
like a version of billboarding uh it's
like wearing your favorite company's
t-shirt but wearing it every day and in
front of thousands of people a day
exactly it's like the twitter equivalent
of having like airpods or nikes on like
everyone's going to see it and it's also
identity building like if you if you
break apart
what makes your brand loyalty like why
would you want to put a crypto punk as
your twitter avatar right or why would
you want to wear nike shoes it's because
you actually feel a sense of procedure
there's either social signaling you're
in the club
or you're thinking you have good taste
right uh you want to be the girl or the
the guy who wears nike shoes every day
or the girl or the guy who has slack
stickers all over his laptop every day
like it becomes this identity-based
affinity for a brand and when you have
that it becomes very hard to compete
with because now it's almost approaching
tribal for better for worse
and just because there's another crypto
punk competitor it doesn't necessarily
mean that they can just take over
through better marketing because better
marketing has a heart will hit a hard
wall against tribalism and building
identity around something that people i
think the way it plays out is
with one
it's good but it's not great as soon as
you get two tribes now they have
somebody to fight and feud with and so
you'll get republicans and democrats
you'll get you know yankees and red sox
on twitter right now you'll get
crypto punks or board apes right board
api club it's the other nft project that
is rivaling them and so people are
switching to those two now you're
probably not going to get like 20 of
these and so there's like room for two
to three tr like main tribes and then
everything else will be very very fringe
and there'll be some people who want
that but okay so you were gonna say
mercury is one of these where do you see
mercury billboard yeah mercury's
interesting because
well let me just back up here and wrap
my head around okay yeah yeah
okay so yeah mercury is a great example
of billboarding because it's a modern
and hyper growth example and it's all
digital i feel like anyone can find an
equivalent way to do the following so
mercury first of all is a bank uh for
startups but not necessarily just
startups and it's become the de facto
startup that yc companies use
so what happens is when yc companies go
to demo day where they fundraise with
investors they
have to then they send a link bingo
bingo so here's the interesting thing
all these investors are now getting
these like pdf wire details with the
label mercury on them yeah and they're
very nice very well formatted looks
beautiful looks better than a normal
bank but you're right it's a silent
signal that i use mercury bingo and it's
also it has this interesting phenomenon
of over sampling which i might be using
a term wrong but you'll get the gist
which is
these vcs are seeing such a high
percentage of startups using mercury
that they're now under the assumption
that everyone's using mercury right or
at least it risks that impression right
and so as a result these vcs when
they're asked by their own portfolio
companies hey should we use mercury
they're like oh yeah everyone uses it
it's like the de facto but is it really
probably not it's how i feel about max
right you go to silicon valley you just
see max everywhere and then you
you're in the filter bubble of everybody
uses max and then you look at the stats
and it's like wait 90 market share for
windows like how is this possible and
it's like yeah because you know
the world is not silicon valley that's
right yeah that's exactly right you can
create this optical impression and if
you're making the impression on a
persona that is itself a distribution
like lightning rod like investors or
like
very high social signal like influencers
if they get the impression of just them
narrowly think that you're everything
right well then they'll act like you're
everything and then finally it trickles
down to the mainstream yes it's like
what it's like high school but for uh
you know 50 year olds um okay so that's
that's growth trend two so we got
trend one
no-brainer
no no brainer no loss offers cool
uh trend two is
the uh the billboard effect you know
either you intentionally create kind of
a status symbol that people choose to
flag or
just in the act of doing business you're
attaching your logo into their world uh
and so everybody that they use the
product with sees you sees you sees you
until it becomes uh sort of like you
know a self it's a free ad basically
that you're getting through your own
customers um what's number three yeah
you got it so number three is
self-liquidating funnels which i know
sort of silly sounding term um it's
actually been around for a long time
this is not really a new thing but very
few founders appear to have heard about
it so let's break down this idea of
self-locating funnels
so the idea here is that let's say you
can't make your facebook ads work
profitably or you can't get them to pay
you back in a reasonable amount of time
like it takes eight months before
someone buys from you after you pay 30
bucks to get their email right
right so self-liquidating basically
means you're offering
some type of product that is secondary
to your main product
so let's say you're selling a 30 ebook
or let's say you're an seo tool and
you're selling a complimentary seo tool
like a content planning tool that's only
five bucks a month as opposed to 200
bucks a month okay and the idea here is
if you decrease the cost of whatever
you're offering but still make it
related to your primary product
people will buy much more reflexively
like they're in the chocolate aisle of
the grocery store
and it's cheaper so lesser consideration
purchase
and um because more will i hopefully
it'll be a higher rate of purchase and a
much quicker turnaround to purchase
it could make the economics of your
facebook ads for example suddenly
totally viable right so
imagine you're doing this just to break
even you're not trying to make money off
it the question is what is the point of
this and this is where it becomes so
clever
is this a giant excuse to print email
addresses because if i can now capture
emails using a self-liquidating funnel
and i'm paying effectively nothing for
these emails they're just it's like
literally self-liquidating hence the
name
then i can now
scale this up to the extent possible
capture let's say a thousand a hundred
thousand emails and now i'm playing the
long game i've just come up with a
fantastic source of lead gen
so that i can nurture those emails those
people over time and eventually sell
them the real product and make the real
margins right so that's the sort of
brilliance of like
going back to my point earlier about if
you think of your product roadmap in
unison with your growth roadmap
what are the product features that can
actually facilitate
much easier growth and i'm not saying
every company has to do this it's just
that if you're having a hard time making
certain channels work these strategies
we're chatting about
um are like
potentially available to you cheat codes
albeit potentially very distracting ones
so there's a lot of concerns to consider
but i'm just giving you guys ideas to
pick from from what i've seen work in
the community so to wrap up this
particular idea sean it basically comes
down to this
if you can't make the economics of an ad
channel exciting
can you at least a not burn money while
b
building a huge lead database that likes
you because your free thing or your
cheap thing rather it's really high
quality right yeah so you see this in
content a lot i think you do this
pretty well i think you have these like
uh
handbooks i think you call them on your
website and it's like
way more
high quality than a blog post
um and so you send them that thing for
free
grab their email address they're happy
because wow i got he over delivered on
value for this free thing
and you're getting emails for free
during that now i don't know if you do
paid ads to run those but many people do
uh you know run paid ads to a free ebook
and then grab the lead there or a five
dollar you know just pay shipping so i
think i think they call this in
marketing the free plus shipping offer
which is you're giving the thing away
for free and you just charge shipping so
they do this with books or like if
you're a clothing brand you can give
away like a little hat and they just pay
the shipping cost the shipping cost kind
of bakes in your cost of goods also
because it's like you know seven dollars
since like shipping is five the cost of
goods is two and you think you're
getting the item for free what do you
have to lose all you gotta do is pay the
shipping that seems fair and they're
they're using that to get your um to get
your information and then they say great
now i'm gonna go back to this list now
they've had a sample of my stuff
and can i go get 25 of people to become
a real customer after doing that
yeah absolutely well the way i think
about it is and this is a strong opinion
of mine that i'm not saying is the right
way is i actually don't sell anything on
my website so julian.com is what you're
referring to where i write these
handbooks like i break down like how to
write well how to grow your startup
there's nothing being sold like there's
some ads for not ads per se but some
references to demandcurve.com where we
teach people growth but by and large if
i'm making money from demand curve
then i don't want to have to make money
from the things i'm doing for pure
enjoyment and that i'm using to build an
audience like i want to build this
association that
you can trust me that i'm never trying
to sell you anything and i think that's
not critically required but so
healthy for the long term and like you
think of paul graham like this you know
the writer guru y.c founder that
everyone looks up to you know in a
million years you would never expect him
to have like a banner ad at the bottom
of a blog post he writes because it'd be
so out of character and it would really
compromise i think or or a 199 course
yeah exactly exactly so yeah so i just
try to keep them totally separate and um
anyway so yeah that's but not i'm not
saying people have to monetize they have
to make a living but if you make a
living through other things you don't
have to make a living to the thing
you're passionate about like when i see
very rich people start podcasts
and still run ads on their podcast
like unless you're doing it to pay
employees you're awesome but if you're
doing because you're trying to make an
extra buck it seems like it's totally
defeats the purpose of why you're let's
call let's call them out reid hoffman
you are a billionaire you created
linkedin you sold it for 20 billion
dollars why does your podcast have ads
uh and i know they're i know the answer
to it actually but uh no excuses as far
as i'm concerned now people can say the
same thing about me i do i think there's
ads on this podcast there are
i do courses and the way i thought about
it was was pretty simple which was
i'm going to spend my time doing
something and i value my time and i also
want to scoreboard for if the thing i'm
doing is valuable and one scoreboard is
likes and the other the i think a more
powerful scoreboard
is money and i do a lot of things for
likes the podcast is free all that's
good stuff
but if i do something like a course or
i'm actually going to sit down spend
time with you and teach you something
then i want to charge for that most of
the time i give away a bunch of like
free spots um and the last thing is i uh
i do this to get myself more excited
about it so i'll set
a um a reason
a goal for the money so i'll be like
okay
like this right now with this course i'm
doing right now
i was like all right i want to do two
things
um i want to be able to i made a list of
10 people who've been just awesome to me
in life
and they've like mentored me or helped
me in some form or fashion i was like i
want to buy them all like a fat gift
like a gift that's like you know way
more than what uh what they would be
expecting in this case the second thing
is i want to
i'm really trying to get in shape and i
was like i want to have a personal chef
i was like how much does that cost i
used to have an investor he had a he had
a personal chef a private chef and the
chef would come cook for us at lunch at
the office every day and it was amazing
and i always just thought that was a one
day one day dream i kind of looked up
the cost and i was like oh i think i
could pay for that that's basically like
you know
six to eight grand a month um okay cool
so if i sell you know if i do a hundred
thousand dollars profit in this course
that pays for
a year of a chef and now i got excited
about it so it made me
more excited to actually do the thing
than just my benevolence and maybe it's
because i'm kind of a
greedy or selfish person that could be
the reason why but all i know is once i
have a target and that target could be
anything silly it could be uh i'm gonna
go buy you know
uh you know go buy a
bunch of crypto pucks or i'm gonna put
it all in on this penny stock and then
i'm gonna turn that into content of
riding the wave of this penny stock
it doesn't really matter what it is is
but when i have a target
then i'm a financial target it makes me
try to do a way better job at the thing
i'm doing yeah that definitely resonates
and i think it's healthy and i think
that's awesome
i see it a bit differently and my
different way is not a better way and my
different way is
i like i see what i spend my time on
outside of like earning a salary through
demand curve.com in the context of
a craftsperson and so i don't want to do
anything even if it's for like some
extrinsic goal like getting a chef um
unless i i would be happy doing it if i
got nothing else from it like the
process itself is the reward
um and i feel like it took a really long
time for me to figure out what those
things are in my life where the process
alone is really rewarding
and to me
so yeah yeah it's just like it's such a
beautiful thing if you can find it um
and and like i was going through this
binge on youtube where i was watching
videos of creators uh and like artists
and musicians in the process of making
their music uh like if you google uh if
you search youtube for ariana grande i
forget the name of the song but she's
like ariana grande in studio dude i've
gone down so many rabbit holes of this
uh there's an ed sheeran documentary if
anybody wants to watch on apple plus of
him making his uh on apple tv plus or
whatever of uh him making his album
and it's like he invites a bunch of
people to his house and you literally
see him like in a car ride just messing
around on the guitar and he's like you
can see you can hear him figuring out
this one guitar lick that became you
know uh you know love yourself or
whatever becomes one of these like hits
today and you can see him just like
humming and being like oh what if i said
you know blah blah and then he's like
figuring it out live
god that that stuff is like you know
that's my business porn that's my
creativity porn yeah it's a dopamine hit
and a great one is if you guys search
john mayer beats live radio on youtube
you'll see him like literally make up a
song in real time it's such a isn't it
such a dopamine hit to watch people but
the thing i take away from all those
videos
is
if they've made no money from that i
know i think deep in my bones i know not
all of these musicians that are
successful but some of them like john
mayer they're just obsessed with doing
this and the reward is can they come up
with something awesome so
um
yeah the the the flip side of that is
the flip side of that is you don't want
john mayer to have to build demand curve
as a business in order to fund his
musical pursuits and so
if
if if this is the thing you love the
most and you want to spend all your time
doing it
and you didn't have some major major
exit beforehand which is a big criteria
for most people then this is how it
becomes sustainable right like i want to
create more content i want to teach so
that i need teaching to be sustainable
so i could spend all my time on it i
could hire the best people for it all
those things right so i think that's the
caveat do you have any kind of like yeah
other backup stuff as far as
opportunities or ideas or things that
caught your eye i have one maybe we'll
keep it quick because i don't know if
it's what you're going to find
interesting so maybe we do this one
super quick and you can pull me along if
you like it how's that okay sounds good
cool so um
okay well actually have i told you my
thoughts on like what goes into making
awesome content like this podcast
no break it down okay yeah yeah i feel
like i feel like i don't remember who i
was telling this to so the short of it
is i think there's this curse of
overcoming frequency and when i was
going through like all the content
creators that i see the most loved
profess for
like weight but y or paul graham who i
mentioned earlier everyday astronaut
right what they all have in common is
they don't publish content on a set
frequency like literally the slogan for
waypoint.com this great blog that people
love is new posts every sometimes at the
end of the everyday astronaut videos
they'll be like the next video will be
out when it's ready and like paul graham
will post at a very erratic schedule and
what they all have in common
is they're publishing when they truly
have something to say
they're not publishing try hit a
deadline which i think is a trap because
you're then forced to try to be a
creative genius
on account on a schedule which is like
near impossible now what do you make of
the like casey neistat uh mr beast or
whoever these guys that basically they
made their their bones and their
following by
doing a daily vlog and they got they
chose to get on that they chose to
handcuff themselves that treadmill
and the fans kind of loved that
and their premise was different it
wasn't this is great it's this is
everything yeah i think it's a great
question so it's a good counter example
i think this general idea i'm getting to
is almost domain specific like it
depends what you're trying to sell if
you're just offering people like cheap
awesome entertainment like money
giveaways the threshold is not that high
to be creatively like fulfilling to hit
that but if you're trying to sit down
like paul graham or wait but why or
james clear or morgan housel like these
authors
and you're trying to come up with
something original and novel to say that
is really where i'm getting at and it's
also not unlike podcasts like can you
actually hit a podcast at a really high
frequency
maybe but at some point you run out of
awesome guests or ideas you get burned
out and so the reason this is on my mind
is because
what i realized is there's this weird
myth
that in order for you to succeed as a
podcaster or vlogger or content creator
or whatever is you have to have a very
consistent and high frequency of output
but that's not true this is like some
1950s mad men era like our billboard
impression crap yeah it's like it
doesn't exist with the internet it's not
the same thing matter-of-factly like if
you look at like my twitter account
i think i got to like 200 000 twitter
followers and i tweet once every 14 days
like twice a month i literally i
literally send two tweets a month um
people aren't forgetting who i am but if
the quality is high the staying power so
much better you don't have to be pumping
out all the time right like wait but why
i think he didn't post anything for like
eight months
you know what i mean so
i just want to sort of encourage people
on this on this momentary platform of my
first million that um really beautiful
things happen you can rise above this
content overload that we live in if you
focus more so on quality the
quantity is useful for yourself like if
you're trying to get good at something
due to high frequency
but that doesn't mean you have to
publish everything
um you can keep some back and do it for
yourself so anyway that's my little rant
on quality events quantity and the
reason i'm bringing this up is because
your podcast is consistently good and i
think the brilliance of it the reason
it's
possible is because you found a format
which the threshold like i was you know
referring to the youtube examples is
achievable like you haven't you haven't
backed yourself into a corner like how i
built this where they have to spend so
long
doing something awesome you can just
grab people riff on ideas and it's a
lower threshold but still incredibly
hard to do don't get me wrong and so
i just yeah i just i just find this
whole topic so interesting because so
many people are pumping out content with
like the wrong framework yeah yeah and i
think there's many ways to win like i
think you typically want to be on either
end of the spectrum either
light touch high frequency so um you
might
i'm comfort i'm like friends there's a
million episodes you can go through and
they're all all right um or your game of
thrones and there's like no there's
eight episodes that you can go go to for
this season but they're all epic and you
know i think
i find that if you're going to choose
one strategy
polarize to either end of that and focus
on
quality um or focus on uh frequency and
um
and in the middle is tough because if
you try to be high frequency high
quality you lose right if you try to be
low frequency low quality you lose if
you try to be right so it's like there's
you have to hit one of those in order to
make it work um as far as i've seen in
terms of in terms of how content goes by
the way tell me uh share with people
your thoughts on
bios so i hit you up and i was like hey
i want to redo my twitter bio and i feel
like you've probably put some thought
into this and you were like
funny enough i have here's some thoughts
and you gave me this audio note this
two-minute imessage audio note that was
fire
and i was like this is such a julian
thing so so share share with people kind
of your what you've seen or how you
break that down the whole idea of bio
which sounds really light-hearted but in
reality
how you talk about yourself matters to
yourself like your own self-concept but
how you talk about yourself to others
how you present yourself to others
it's like it seems frivolous until you
gotta go write one and then you sit down
you're like
i have so much to say that i have
nothing to say at the same time it all
sounds bad then it sounds too braggy
then it sounds too unimpressive
how do i do this and so give me give me
your thoughts on
bios sure so this isn't a hard and fast
rule it's just what i think makes the
most sense and i'd love to hear a better
idea
which is
write your bio to justify why people
should follow you by the way let's let's
just just stick with twitter for now
that's what we're talking about here so
write your twitter bio
that justifies why you're differentiated
and worth following what do people get
from following you so for example mine
is something like
i deconstruct i'm literally reading my
bi right now so it goes like this i
deconstruct how things work like
storytelling and critical thinking and i
share my learnings along the way okay so
you know what you're getting now and the
reason this distinction is important
well actually let's compare and contrast
so the typical bio is something like
forbes 30 under 30 2x founder 3x father
5x christian like all these all these
stats
you know and it's like and it's like
this doesn't tell me anything it's just
virtue signaling in to some respect
and i don't know why i should care
so the second part of this is it's not
just why they should follow but also
what is the minimal amount of social
proof to justify
why you talking about the topics you're
saying you'll talk about
you actually are qualified to do so so
so you're kind of saying
what are you gonna get from me what's in
it for you
and
why you can trust this source just
enough to get you to trust not
everything bingo and it's what's
interesting about this question actually
sean is that
you're fundamentally asking me a growth
marketing question
which is hey if i look at my twitter
account my twitter profile and if we
think of it as like a landing page for
my startup
what would you do to modify either one
to increase conversions so in
conversions with the startup we're
talking about clicking and signing up
but on twitter we're talking about
clicking and following and so you could
if you actually dive into the weeds
there's more you could do to your
twitter profile
and maybe it's a fun exercise we can
walk through because it just shows how
to apply the lens of growth marketing to
twitter or to youtube or to your podcast
right right so i'll give you one quick
example like if you just think ask
yourself this question
if i'm presenting the public with a page
of any sort
what are all of the elements that
surface on that page that factor into
their decision as to whether they're
going to convert so if i'm looking at my
twitter account right now i'm seeing my
bio i'm seeing my head shot i'm seeing
my pinned tweets so let's just talk
about that let's use that one example
pin tweet so your pin tweet can
reinforce what your bio said to further
qualify why you talk about that
why you should talk about it rather and
it gives an example of it so they get
the quick dopamine hit off the bat that
your pin tweet is delivering on like for
me i said i talk about storytelling and
critical thinking so
my pin tweet is exactly it's just a tiny
little blog post little essay yeah
exactly exactly so that's your surface
area um and the same thing goes for
youtube like every little thing is
surface area
when added together can increase
conversion you know
yeah so you uh and then you have like
the follower account which is like your
social proof that you can't really fake
i guess you can buy fake followers but
that's the other signal that they're
looking for is do other people trust
this person do other people follow this
person um or the blue check mark right
that's that's another signal that that
you can you can have or not have not
fully in your control but
that's what counts towards conversion
all right i like that um wait sean tell
me about your blue checkmark journey
didn't you where do you say something an
imessage your blue check uh
no what do you mean i don't have one i
tried to get one they said
they just didn't reply because that's
twitter uh i don't remember was
something else okay so i remember you
had a story about trying to get it never
mind we'll skip it
you know if you remember it say it i i
don't remember it maybe maybe you're
mixing me up with somebody no that that
actually might have been this it might
even be the world's worst story that
might have been it's never mind
fair enough fair enough um okay i think
we can we can uh leave it with kind of
like
one last little piece and then we'll
we'll wrap it up to go but the last
thing i wanted to say is if you weren't
doing what you were doing now right so
you're not doing demand curve you're not
writing i can't i can't let you go back
through those doors those doors are now
locked
where does julian go how does he spend
his time what what would excite you if i
gave you all your time back
where would you go spend it if you
couldn't spend it how you're spending it
now so the answer i actually know
reflexively is
movies like the thing i actually came to
the us to do from canada
was to try to make movies and so that
remains the thing that i find
so interesting because it's i don't have
a good it's gonna be hard for me to
explain this but the brief version is
it's so freaking hard sean like it's so
hard to break in it's so hard to write a
good screenplay it's so hard to turn
that into a good film it's so hard to
get people to watch it and and the the
requirements for actually pulling it off
are how resourceful how creative and how
sort of um
uh well really those are the two key
things resourceful and creative you can
be and that do you have a good sense of
taste right right and i love that
forcing i love that burden on my
shoulders try to crack what i see is one
of the hardest
problems the intersection like creative
and business so i've always wanted to do
it plus i just love the idea of being
able to tell people stories that moves
them it's such a beautiful thing so what
kind of movies are we talking like
comedy
action drama
indie artistic you know
documentaries what are you talking about
well i'll tell you i'll give you four
movies i absolutely love and i think
it'll answer the question so
whiplash incredible fiction film
um the prestige uh christopher nolan's
film about magicians uh and then a
documentary on netflix which i'm so
stoked i get to tell people this because
some will actually go well enough people
will listen that it'll get some views
searching for sugar man on netflix is
the best documentary i've ever seen and
then the last one i'll recommend is
who's that one about who's who's the
sugarman okay so this is really tricky
sean because the entire movie is a
spoiler so i'll just say i'll just say
this i'll say
it's about a musician that disappeared
often like the face of the earth
um
and
where he went to and how he came back
and uh you should cut that i'm
getting spoilers i should believe that
we gotta believe the enemy came back uh
but the last thing i'll say is a
counterpart which is um this amazing
show on amazon is my favorite tv show
maybe ever counterpart's amazing it's
it's like a james bond type saying it's
brilliant okay i've never even heard of
that uh i'm not pitching anything well
sean i suck at this
you're great at things until they become
very personal like when it's like what
do you really want to do in your heart
of hearts you're like i don't know how
to say it but like you can say
everything else or it's like these
movies that you love that you really
want other people to love
the pressure in your head goes so high
how do i sell this right without ruining
the the first time magic of experiencing
it um you almost create a a
pressure cooker for yourself here so um
okay so what you want to do is you want
to make you want to make a movie about
uh you know searching for bobby fischer
style right
about you know kobayashi the uh the
competitive eater it's like greatness
slash enigmas slash prodigies
um
and like you know within it with a dash
of sort of drama and mystery dude well i
see i knew i knew i could rely on you
yes well pitched um yeah i just love
this stuff i just i love making it i
love watching i love people i love
seeing people watch it how about you i'm
here i want to flip this around on you
what would you do if i could do anything
right now um yeah i would basically take
like little three to five year arcs of
my life
that's what i think i would do i'd take
three to five year arcs of my life
and i would go try to do
a really fun thing that i don't do so i
would one would be
um stand-up comedy so i would try to
create a set that actually is good and i
would figure out how you do that i would
learn the learn the trade i would go to
shows i would do all that
i would um i would coach a basketball
team
and i would try to like be a high school
basketball coach and uh and just give it
my all you know dude doing that i would
um you know like one is i don't actually
want to make a show but i do want to
write a script i'm actually trying to do
that right now trying to write a script
for a mock episode of the office uh
which is a lot of fun and uh i would try
to make a song like a hit song how do
you make a catchy hit song that pops off
uh i don't care if it pops off as a tic
toc meme or what but but that would be
another one and so i would just do these
little like i'll try to write a book i
would try to create a um a brand of a
drink or a chips bag or something like
that i would just take these like little
mini mini challenges that are three to
five year sprints i would go really deep
in them try to win and then i would come
out the other side i would basically
switch careers uh each time i do them i
love that so you want to you want to
break up your life into chapters and you
want each to be a very creatively
fulfilling thing where you're like
maximally using uh actually not
necessarily because the high school
basketball coach is a really cool one
it's a nice counter balance to the
creative screenwriting thing yeah
because it's not all about making a song
and making a stand-up set it's like
things that i just think would be really
fun if you did them
um
and which typically is creative but
sometimes it's not right like sports is
its own thing competition is really fun
leading is fun strategy is fun all that
good stuff what's stopping you from
being a comedian in the next 15 years
because what stop you from making the
time to do it uh nothing i'm just
occupied right now like i'm doing things
i got a business i'm running and
uh this content arm so
i don't have the clear schedule at the
moment to to clear everything off to go
go chase that and i can just dabble kind
of like for fun in very small ways but i
think there's something really fun about
the immersion so
i've set myself this challenge to try to
write an episode of the office by the
end of this month
and um i don't know how to do it but i
hit up my friend who writes for a tv
show and i said hey can we jam next
thursday and tell me how you write an
episode of tv like that's what i'm
trying to do so i'm i'm doing little
like you know tiptoe in the water but uh
to do it for real the way i want i would
um like i'm gonna clear my schedule for
for like a two to two year period you
won't hear about me and then i come out
the other side uh you know with some
some story to tell
you you know fun would be for all of us
to watch you go do a set i would 100
show up live i would be the loudest
laugher even if it was artificial i
would 100 support you um dude that would
be
i kind of want to live through you sean
it's something i really want you to do
almost selfishly but also i think you'll
just have a blast yeah i i i do and i
will so so the other thing right now is
i just had a kid uh two kids actually
two babies and so i kind of feel like
right now
the main project is actually i'm trying
to get the best shape of my life and i'm
also learning how to be a dad like a new
dad and so i kind of want to like not
skip that part because uh
like i already already made the baby so
i already did the hard part now i just
have to like stay there don't don't busy
myself doing something else just stay
here and actually do a dad bit well what
i will say is if i've learned anything
from comedians endlessly talking about
their process it's that
this is exactly the fuel in your life
that turns into the comedy right like
the struggles of being a dad right the
struggles of losing weight yeah exactly
so it almost seems like
if you don't act on it now it almost
seems like this is the time capsule
where you write down your experiences
and your thoughts and it can become
future material
i'll give you two so i was in the shower
of the day and i wrote down two pieces
uh two pieces of content and i texted it
to some guy who is a comedian
that is pretty famous comedian i don't
know him very well but we kind of we
text her dm a little bit
and i said hey i got two little nuggets
for you two little truths about life
that i think you could turn into jokes
here they are
and uh it's just they'd come to me while
i was in the shower and one was
um
receipts like i don't care how old i get
i got no strategy when it comes
to if i'm at the cashier they say do you
want the receipt
i say yes i say no there is no
consistency there is no logic there is
no strategy and like
nothing is a more panic moment than
whatever the i do when they ask me
do you want the receipt or not and why
like
why do we do that why why does nobody
have like any kind of consistency with
that the second one uh what was the
second one i sent him it was uh oh
racism it's like people think america is
really racist um and there's racism is a
big problem
and when you think of racist like if i
say racism you know think of a racist
what image pops into your head um
the ku klux klan member right so you
know you think of the the
kkk like a white guy in a white hood
or you think of like you know a
white person in a maga hat or something
like that that's what people think of
when they're thinking of racist like who
are all these racists in america right
and uh
and it just occurred to me like in
reality nobody is white people are the
least racist nobody is more racist than
like you know an indian parent or a
chinese grandmother like they'll just
straight up tell you like you know some
pretty
like hey can i marry you know a person
of this race and it's like uh no and
here's why and and so i just it sort of
occurred to me that nobody's more racist
than a chinese grandma and uh and so i
was like you know that's a truth about
the world that i believe that i was like
okay these are nuggets i want to write
down i don't know how you craft those
into jokes like what i'm telling you
isn't a joke
it's just sort of like an observation
of the world the way i see it and then
like okay cool how do i write these down
so that
i learn how to actually like turn these
into jokes and weave them together and
make a set out of it and that's exactly
what i think is the most interesting
part is like what's the scaffolding
what's the narrative structure for
taking that observation and making it
laugh out loud funny is it post like
just a smirk on my face right and this
is where it gets so fun to sit down and
reverse engineer like dave chappelle um
and this is actually one of the podcast
episodes we did uh storytelling is
you're trying to reverse engineer what
makes such a great storyteller and it's
like setting up the stakes the hero's
perspective all these cool ingredients
the climax the twist right um
and that to me is the joy that's got to
be the most fun part i think is you
figuring how to craft it and then the
people who totally buck the trend like
mitch hedberg i actually you know he has
a joke that's sort of like your receipt
joke but my point though first is he's
like not really doing the normal joke
structure i don't think i'm not an
expert right but it's still so funny
because he has an extra layer
the extra layer is phenomenally unique
and like like like tickling delivery
right and so there's an extra layer
beyond the structure of the narrative
like if you just wrote his jokes on
paper it might not be as funny but he
has this joke going back to your
receipts thing where he's like uh people
who hand out flyers on the street as you
pass by for like whatever you know
organization they're running they're
basically saying hey you throw this in
the garbage and i remember that always
stuck in my head and like i can't do
that i can't deliver it like he can
right that's pretty good he got me to
laugh actually there's a thing you
there's a thing you would put out in
your uh storytelling thing by the way
you you said oh here's all these
elements but the one that stood out that
i actually was telling ben uh my
right-hand man i was like hey
uh julian had this thing that i think is
spot-on and we should like i think i i
do this to an extent i think you should
do it more but like we could we can all
do this more you were saying something
like
the best storytellers when they tell a
story it's almost like they're blowing
their own mind again live they are they
are surprising themselves again they're
they're or in a comedian's case they're
making themselves laugh they're cracking
themselves up
and um
the extent to which you can genuinely
blow your own mind repeatedly or crack
yourself up repeatedly is pretty much
the extent to which you can deliver a
story or a joke and um if once you
realize that you can't unsee it and it
gives you a blueprint to just be more
charismatic and entertaining when you
talk that's spot on so the way i can the
way i realize that is there's this
person we interviewed on the pod called
jason silva who for my money is the most
charismatic person on youtube jason
silva and i was sitting there trying to
reverse engineer what made him so damn
good then i eventually got him on my
podcast and i asked them like what's
going on here and he said
julian before i even turn on the camera
i first make sure i'm in a mental space
where i'm experiencing the idea i'm
about to talk about like i was for the
very first time because all of his
videos are like interesting
philosophical concepts and so he sits
there and he's like oh yeah that's what
was so
mind-blowing about it he like chews on
it lets it sink in turns on the camera
light goes red and now he relives that
initial impression and then it's it's
it's infectious he is the person he's
the proxy that we now live through
and it's just it's such a beautiful
thing to see someone fully interact in
their own excitement without any concern
for
like no self-consciousness like
what are my hands doing am i stuttering
where am i looking it's like all these
things fade away when you can get
absorbed by your own enthusiasm and then
people people just love seeing that it's
so authentic yeah exactly it was totally
spot on and if you're going to like try
one thing try that get yourself into the
state where you remember what it felt
like
so that you re you re
you tell it with that same emotion that
you felt when it happened
if you were mind blown then you'll feel
mind blown now if it cracked you up the
first time you realized it it'll crack
you up now and uh i love that i thought
that was a great great little hack great
little deconstruction uh on your part um
all right where should people so twitter
is at julian
julian.com your branding is kind of
amazing amazing um where else should
people follow you yeah sure so really
it's uh julian.com and then
demandcurve.com is where uh all these
ideas we chatted about that's where they
come from we teach people how to do
growth marketing and that's basically it
and then if you want to see sean himself
on my pod uh there's brainzpodcast.com
yeah that's right i think i'm on two
episodes of it so yes dude so we call
you an honorary brain because cory and i
love you so much for like all right even
though it's kind of weird to have one
person twice in the first six episodes
there's no one more lovable and
charismatic and just fun and interesting
and juicy mental models and like a bag
of cool ideas in the back of his brain
and we're like we just we love you i
love you and so thank you for coming on
it's awesome i appreciate you thank you
so much uh all right sweet we're out of
here all right
[Music]
i feel peace i could rule the world i
know i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like my days off on
the road let's travel never looking back